I want to talk about the oh so boring
Oscars the 90th Academy Awards that
racked up the lowest ratings in the
serve in his history why was that
because people be sick of being preached
at by a bunch of posturing hypocritical
lobbies virtue signaling and ramming
their politics down our throats people
have had it up to here with rich
privileged celebs lecturing the rest of
us on our carbon footprint while slang
around the world in private jets or
droning on about Trump's war while
living in gated mansions and then
there's the times up me two Brigade who
used the three hours 48 tedious minutes
of the Oscars and every other reward so
means this yeah to score political
points these women really see themselves
as radicals changing the world while
protesting in dresses that cost an
average person's annual salary
it isn't always wrong for celebrities to
use their fame to promote a cause but
these self-righteous political speeches
have to stop and if that means banning
them so be it the journalist Ella Whelan
said this week that quotes feminism is
merely the latest must-have accessory
well it's time they put the accessory
away stop with all the political
speeches and did what they do best act
[Music]
how you've spent most of your life as I
understand it as a journalist on popular
newspaper yeah popular newspapers
survived by these sort of quotes from
people in the you know from stars from
people who around them that's what they
survive on that's something not
political but about but it's about
taking notice of these people when
probably you shouldn't take any notice
of you there's not just want you to have
a look at this clip to just show you how
up themselves they are I think we have a
responsibility to speak up and and and
talk about social and justice and change
and we have the platform to do it
certainly because we are any
entertainment industry I think this
perform
extremely special because we got to
honor you know amazing heroes like
Nicole Hockley here and the work that
they're doing you know fighting against
gun violence and and you know feeding
people in Puerto Rico you know to me and
fighting for equal justice and so for us
today that was the real honor okay the
first person was actress Allison Janney
why in god's name does she think that
because she's in the entertainment why
she's in the entertainment of Z she has
a responsibility to speak out bears and
Andrea in this Andrea day she says the
honor was to honor somebody called Nick
Hawtree who's fighting against gun
violence and your eyes first of all you
are very vocal about your views against
this sort of stuff yes
so why are you more why do you why do
you have more validity to express your
views than them at the end of the day we
live in a democracy we live in a society
that promotes freedom of speech is that
the point is you're journalists and
actually let's not forget you know all
of these celebrities and not those two
but a lot of them I've worked with
Rachel you've worked with a lot of them
on campaigns the fact is people listen
to them if somebody with a hundred
million Twitter followers or 150 million
Instagram viewing figures this year will
tell you that about celebrities in
general charity scandal means that they
listen to them they used to look actors
are the following someone else writes
their words someone else tells them
where to stand and someone else has
tells them to whom they should address
their words you you sit on the radio
every day about an hour with you
I will do I agree with Carol I can't
actually agree there is too much of it
there is too much of this use of the use
of these awards but to sort of and you
and I don't like banning I know that you
don't like censoring have a quiet word
can we tone it down yes but stop it all
together the most of the day and and
there was three of them on stage night
and I'm not allowed to name whom people
bury they said our voices have carved a
new path not the new path to the xxx
unknown actresses who had everything to
lose who'da spoke to the night they
called actresses were able to amplify
that they don't abandon my breath who
saw as they saw they wouldn't have got
the same attention no way I mean I
partly agree I think these endless award
ceremonies that come around every five
minutes are like Moga Don's to get you a
nomination be making a long speech when
I lose again I think that Carol you'd be
equally disappointed if these
celebrities did have a platform and
actually failed to say something of any
utility no I will be deformed but I mean
we've got to give credit where it's due
and I mean let me just mention one Amal
Clooney love who is married to George
Clooney who is using the fact that she's
a beautiful barrister to try and get
justice for the rape victims of the
Yazidi genocide in the UN now because
she's a mild Clooney she's getting a
proper hearing the some of the victims
have actually given speeches that have
reduced the entire UN General Assembly
to tears are you saying she shouldn't
use it where she is entirely do you know
will be married to George Clooney a
famous person given was given I heard
that platform that internationally also
shows you count this is the
the Weinstein scandal because of that it
was relevant at an award ceremony for
the film industry yeah I mean it really
walk now I agree with you if it goes on
year after year exactly thank you that
you've done this brilliantly for me Greg
I take you back 40 years to the year
when paddy Chayefsky an American
screenwriter and you'll appreciate more
of his work a little bit later in the
show I warn you now paddy Chayefsky
screenwriter at the Oscars of 1978 I
would like to say personal opinion of
course that I'm sick and tired of people
exploiting the occasion of the Academy
Award for the propagation of their own
personal political propaganda that was
1978 that's how that's been going on at
some stage someone's gonna say look we
know it's too much of these 30 words
it's now something like a hundred nation
unless you're Gary Oldman but people
don't people don't watch it and won't be
part of it then they'll change it but
you mentioned Weinstein there isn't it
funny that in the year that we we know
that went in there the monster has been
exposed the film Piers Morgan said
there's it made me laugh the film that
won the Best Picture was a film about a
vile looking monster falling in love
with him you woman I mean no one wants
to watch this is one of those worthy
anyway that's that's but it will never
be too much for all the women who have
been harassed for all the women who have
been abused for them they are very happy
that somebody but I think limiting their
calls so it's never gonna be enough
we're never a little bit reduced and the
fix up I think they've reduced politics
to crying about all those poor women out
there this is this is a bunch of the
richest most privileged women effort in
the world it takes they think they think
in that quality is getting paid fifteen
million dollars a movie when their male
co-star gets 20 million dollars they
don't know what inequality means and
that's that's the sort of stuff they
stand there you know I love life dude
right the women who
to sleep with casting director allegedly
you know heads of Studios in order to
otherwise they didn't get the gig here's
an interesting point there's a and you
know my discovered Harvey Weinstein's
lawyers a guy called Ben Brafman now you
know Weinstein zestes Bob we know that
but he voiced when I think is quite an
uncomfortable truth this week and he
said that was his truth I think it's
were not comfortable I think I think it
is a truth he says beautiful young women
in Hollywood and everywhere else wield
the most enormous power and he and he
said that that women's campaign women's
camp penguins don't acknowledge this
they only see victim and predator and
even and he says you know if if a woman
decides to sleep with a Hollywood
producer to advance her career what she
has done is made a decision okay I would
have fiction I shall take home at one
point and then I'd like to add just add
to that which is a woman obviously has
agency and can decide what she wants to
do but I think that we have to I think
what's come out of the whole me to
movement is if the man has power in that
relationship then it is not necessarily
consensual in a way that we should
approve but that one has power with her
be known her you let me finish but also
while we are living under a system of
patriarchy the problem is that that
woman's youth and beauty that you're
talking about is often exploit you and
you will use it I would have said you
are I didn't say that the woman has
power would you admit that when a that
often it I like that we live in a
society that for centuries has only
valued you've just you just proved my
point that the email current yeah too
long has been beg your side you see
attractiveness yeah and I don't want to
use a word honor but it's nubile you
know they are of childbearing in any you
know if that to their advice don't deny
because for Rachel that women fluff
minnow
goes cuz we're denying that but where
things got a look at why and that's what
needs to get there anyway